hey 42 here cartographers used to
include fake towns on their maps to
catch forgers welcome to RIF Sudan is
the only country that still has
crucifixion as an official form of
capital punishment famous left-handed
people include Napoleon da Vinci
Michelangelo Einstein Newton Bill Gates
Oprah Obama and Jimi Hendrix honey bees
always know where the Sun is even if
it's on the other side of the world you
have a better chance of getting accepted
to Harvard University than you do at
getting a job at an Apple Store for some
reason South Korean soap operas are
popular in Cuba crime disease and
average walking speed increase by 15% as
a city doubles in size within 200 yards
of the flattened Islington where George
Orwell had the idea for 1984 there are
now 32 CCTV cameras every living thing
can be anesthetized even plants
despite their successful use since the
mid 19th century no one really
understands how anesthetics work
India has a higher population than the
entire Western Hemisphere elephants have
the longest pregnancy in the animal
kingdom at 22 months the longest human
pregnancy on record is 17 months 11 days
in the u.s. meat is treated with carbon
monoxide to make it look fresh
India has a bill of rights for cows in
1980 a Las Vegas hospital suspended
workers for betting on when patients
would die thanks for the view subscribe
for more thoughty2